and public thank you for that I welcome
you to this meeting of the council this
evening if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices by the stairs
either through the security doors of the
dorsum i right or upset the listing the
FOIA please do not use the lifts
assemble in holy square on the green and
officers will assist you and advise you
when it seems safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
brought on the broadcast on the internet
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured so I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film the
meeting thank you very much any member
of the public who objects to the
possibility of viewing films may wish to
take this opportunity to leave any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and the public from the
meeting and finally with everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent that they
are not used to make or receive phone
calls in the chamber whilst this meeting
is in progress to our agenda then agenda
item number 1 apologies for absence we
have apologies from counselors brim
Dennis Dawson Evans Ian Gregory Ken
Gregory and councillor partington are
there any other apologies
cancel Rajesh thank you very much and so
Gary human thank you very much would
members please refer to supplementary
agenda item number one the minutes of
the meeting held on the 9th of februari
2017 I move that the minutes of the
meeting of this council held on the 9th
of februari 2017 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second cig indeed the
members agree Thank You Jen director
number three on announcements I've not
been formed informed of any
announcements so agenda item number four
are there any declarations of interest
thank you very much agenda item number
five then remain agenda petitions to the
council
and 5a is access to Hodges gap from
menards carpark a petition containing 45
valid signatures has been received by
the council and I am pleased to welcome
miss singer to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
you
thank you Miss singer you have up to
three minutes to speak to Council
Councillor ladies and gentlemen I'm here
to find out why an orderly member of the
public has been allowed to block access
to a council car park I'm referring to
the barrier leading to the ologies gap
from innate car park about three months
ago a second lock appeared on this
barrier most barriers and planets have a
padlock for which relevant parties are
key ie emergency services I've been told
that this barrier has not been lots of
standard for the past 40 years initially
and our I and many others would be users
of the car park found that the barrier
had been locked with a standard padlock
overnight inconvenience but usually we
found it open during the day suddenly a
second padlock was being used the police
informed me that they do not have a key
for this padlock as how the person who
maintains the life boys no access
presumably neither do other emergency
services it seems that the jet ski cafe
leaseholder put on this padlock
according to the Land Registry the jet
ski cafe leaseholder only Lisa's the
cafe and the yellow yellow marked face
the rest of the land on Hajus cup is not
least and has been used by the residents
of sonnets and its visitors Palm Bay
Beach is the only [ __ ] in Margate that
can be used by dogs all year round
unfortunately now the only option is to
park just outside the barrier to Hodges
gap or go down and up a flight of stairs
or rump I as well as others have an
issue going down up or both many have
simply stopped going to the beach I have
often seen people come down only to
leave again even the parents of the
scouts how to pick up the children from
the top of the cliff at the end of last
summer the Gazoo barrier had been
padlocked when the tidal pool was
emptied and children came to look at the
wildlife before school
the parents had parked in front of both
barriers it was chaos there is a
reasonable expectation and furthermore a
precedent that there is access to the
Hodges gap culminate in order to park
because of the signs are there they are
for drivers it's a car park and yet
cannot be used as one this means that a
large section of the population is being
denied access such as the elderly people
with disabilities wheelchair users and
people with small children using
postures it's unintentionally
discriminatory it also represents a
health and safety risk since the
emergency services do not have access
I'm sure that this padlock is not
official I have witnessed the van
arriving at the barrier on several
occasions being let in and then the
barrier again being locked with both
padlocks this creates the impression for
the whole areas for the sole benefit of
the car seat only I don't believe this
is right thank you thank you very much
fishing it in accordance with our
councils petition schemes a petition
will be referred to cabinet without
debate this evening for a report to come
back to Council within three ordinary
meetings thank you for coming to be on
the beach thank you and I backup letter
from a lady with a tumor we stopped
going to the beach thank you for coming
to a council
[Applause]
agenda item number five B then the
petition to change the number nine bus
route and the reports provides members
with an update regarding a petition
considered by council on the 13th of
October 2016 cancel the matter face as
you represented the petition to the
quality bus partnership on behalf of the
council would you please like to update
us on events yes of course sure happy to
I took it to the Senate quality bus
partnership explained the situation
explained why people were anxious about
this service and I was assured that the
next meeting they would be able to come
back and under action points they're
really really tough on action points I
would have the information which I level
other folks are happy to pass on at the
next meeting thank you very much
remembers please note the report thank
you gender actor number six questions
from the press and the public one
question has been received from a member
of the public in accordance with council
procedure rule number 13 please note
that only the question of the respondent
are permitted has become a question and
if the questioner is not present at the
meeting their question can't be put but
will be replied to in writing because
the questioner please only state the
name of the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
have submitted to cancel the question is
regarding fanuc GP surgeries and I'm
pleased to welcome miss Gregory to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table
question 2 councillor fairbrass cabinet
member for community services NHS
England in its sustainability and
transformation plans proposed reducing
the 16 planet GP surgeries 24 will the
council through the health and
well-being board please confirm or deny
this or determine whether it refers only
to some community provisions and not to
the full range of general practice thank
you
thank you Jeff and thank you for your
question a core theme of the CCG
sustainability transformation plan is to
improve local out of hospital care
infinite the season EG are looking at
doing this using the primary care home
model this is an approach to support
primary care and the local services
clustered around them to work together
and reshape the way services are
delivered it is based on local
population needs and ensuring
sustainability primary care home areas
generally provide care to defined
populations of between 30,000 and 50,000
people infinite we will have four areas
or localities broadstairs Margate quakes
and ramsgate the idea is that
constituent practices within those areas
will work in conjunction and
collaboratively to make primary care
stable and sustainable as well as start
to work with other providers of health
and care services in the NHS local
authority and voluntary sectors to
provide real integrated local services
this doesn't necessarily mean fewer GP
practices it means that they will work
together at a larger scale it is
acknowledged that sometimes GP partners
that hold individual contact contracts
with NHS England from April 2017 at VCC
gee that will manage these want to merge
or hand back their contracts but when
this occurs the CCG work with local
partners patients and GPS to find a
solution that is sustainable for the
future and ensures that patients still
will have a good service we also need to
face the challenge of the shrinking
numbers of GPS mainly due to retirement
this is a national problem and fan it is
not a new in recent years practices of
clothes and patients have had to
register elsewhere the primary care more
home model will help us to develop
services that work better for patients
and are more attractive to GPS
one of those ideas has been recently
child is that of sharing data so that
patient can choose to go to another
practice if their own has a longer wait
for an appointment by sharing the load
the part of these plans for ccg are
looking at buildings too they want to
use money from an NHS England estate
technology and transformation fund to
help establish integrated health and
well-being centers which will sometimes
be called hubs they're currently looking
at the feasibility of such centers in
margate Westwood crosslands gates and
quakes and alongside this they will
review their existing buildings their
aim is to develop primary care and local
care services that work better for our
population and staff and a fit for the
future I will be asking to be kept
updated and I will be monitoring these
plans through the health and well-being
board thank you thank you agenda item
number 7 questions from members of the
council would members please note that
items seven a question regarding planet
play areas has been withdrawn by the
questioner so we moved to seven be
briefing to members with members please
refer to the supplementary agenda number
one and I call these on counselor
Savitch thank you very much chairman
river oaks draft statement or community
consultation intense engagement with
wider public debate which a present does
not include this chamber for fairness
and impartiality since AVX gave a
presentation to TDC can the leader
advise white is not his intention to
offer river oak the same opportunity
thank you thank you i call upon count to
the world's to respond thank you a
question counsel Savage ah it is
important to understand that it is river
of responsibility to manage the
consultation of their pre application
process nor mine I understand from the
pings website and thin
from information now received from river
oak directly that river oak are
currently consulting with the local
authorities on the content of their
draft statement acuity consultation the
timescale for comments on this document
run to the tenth of march i believe and
there is then a pause whoever wrote to
show that they have taken on board the
comments made to them by the local
authorities they have approached and
product the consultation itself
according to reverse own documentation
which is due to run between may and july
of this yet there is an another pause as
a result the consultation i've written
up and analyzed and as I understand the
process shared once again with the local
authorities concerned prior application
being able to begin according to counsel
procedures as the formal consultation
processes other taken by river oak it
will be the responsibility of the
executive to respond on behalf of the
council you can imagine that there are
many such consultations which take place
each year requiring a response and is
impractical for all councillors to
respond on each occasion however
individual cancers will presumably have
the opportunity to take part in any or
all of the public consultation processes
which will be offered by river oak some
of which detail is contained within the
draft statement includes consultations
referred to in your question the full
response from the council is being
worked on by operatives right now and
will be returned before the deadline I
have looked at River Oaks proposed draft
myself because it is now appeared to
have been released in the public domain
and on a first read I had a couple of
operation by observer see that the new
company image and logo proposed a PhD
branded you keep personal yellow which I
thought with the interesting choice
given all the circumstances as has been
the tradition in many river oak
documents presented to this council it
seems to lack a some of the important
detail we might expect in particular in
river oak documents a tradition in river
documents I think that some of this
stuff is not present but in particular I
would draw your attention to the map
showing potential noise impacted areas
which seems to me pretty basic and
pretty
direct to the point of being almost
useless and he appears to assume that no
one who lives under a potential flight
path could be noise impact turbo
operations which i think is interesting
assertion like that will last very long
when public going comes in but what's
more important than that the phrase to
be confirmed pops up several times
throughout and what's a fair least in
document though it does have many glossy
pictures I would ish ly observe that the
council as well as pins will be looking
for evidence of lessons learned by river
oak from their last round of public
consultation particularly areas of dates
protection and security use of campaign
volunteers in key roles including the
infamous security guard issues which
pins raised the complaints they received
directly with the Rope about
intimidation that was claimed to have
taken place at public events your
question puzzle of me in one respect in
that the introduction to that very
statement that River Oaks say that they
are consulted with both TDC and KCC on
this matter already presumably enough to
satisfy themselves that's the
information discussion they require I
remind you as I states at the start of
the center under the protocol of any
potential dped certification in the
future they actually begin at some
points that River are responsible for
managing the stages of their own
pre-application and making necessary
arrangements not us your question would
appear to differ from River Oaks own
written introduction that they have
already consulted presumably to the
roadside attraction prior to the
drafting of this document
constitutionally Avior are in a
different position to river oak AVR made
presentations to cancers because they
wrote a report for this council on the
local plan and the local plan is a
matter which has to be agreed by council
and it's not there for Sony's
responsibility of the executives and of
course as was often be explained the
local plan is required to be based on
evidence it was there to comment that a
robust evidence base is multi noted
strength of river oaks interactions with
this council to date nor of their
interactions with avo or ktv
indeed with some who attended the
previous consultations run by them let
us all hope that is about to change so
we can all judge the potential viability
of what they propose although based on
their current draft statement and it's
map reference to the village of minister
robust proofreading would appear to be a
challenge for them let alone robust
evidence Chancellor savage do you have a
supplementary question well of course
chairman thank you yeah well I take all
that on board and thank you very much
for all of that quite long quite
retracted however can he explain why
counselors in this chamber are not
deserving of an equal hearing from river
oak which would surely help them take a
balanced view when deciding the future
of the airport site in relation to the
emerging local plan for which they would
all have to have a say Thank You
chairman an attractive and length it
might have been but it is clear one
thing this is not a consultation over
which I have control and if you look at
the statement or qet compensation
football I river oak there is nothing
and no request of that type contained
within it as has happened before in this
chamber I suggest you're asking the
wrong people the right questions thank
you agenda item number eight motions
have noticed no motions of notice have
been received in accordance with council
procedure rule three so we move to
agenda item number nine the leaders
report and I call upon the Leland yet oh
it's couldn't could I have a word about
this before you open your items please
and the Constitution actually says that
the leader of the council will make
available in writing the content of his
oral report to opposition group leaders
no later than Saturday before the
meeting sweet will not exceed ten
minutes on key issues arising since the
last meeting of the council
now at a meeting that was held some time
ago as a concession at least to the
opposition leaders agreed that it was
acceptable for the leader to send bullet
points the Saturday before the meeting
and that the transcript of the actual
speech he was going to make would arrive
with this the day before well this time
although it was some three weeks ago
rather than last Saturday we were
advised it was going to talk on one
topic which was the merger the
transcripts arrived did arrive the day
before but it arrived at ten past ten
years to be even which doesn't really
seem to be in the spirit of the
Constitution anyway but it actually
references for further topics but
they're also more importantly and more
worryingly four paragraphs is fortuitous
politicking and I think that's totally
unacceptable I think it shows content
for the Constitution content for this
chamber are more importantly contempt
for You chairman because once counts the
world's have said something it's too
late you can't stop them from doing it
so to help you tonight i've made a copy
of the transcript highlighted be
offending paragraphs and invite me to
have a read so you can rule out of order
the things that shouldn't be being said
to see
[Applause]
after Wells because it could have just
over a month free
conservation thank you very much i have
passed the amended copy to count the
world who will now deliver it with some
of those items Rimmer's
okay i will start with a simple cadre
what's happened here this evening which
is that the intention of the sharing of
the script or so that the opposition
leaders should be aware of what was
going to be said we'll give them a fair
chance to produce a response of course
that arrangement in future will have to
be I'll have to send you the script you
will have to send your responses so it's
an even playing field so I mean you know
carefully wishful the latest report yeah
the lead is before I beg your pardon
well I then you should as well
cancellation the leaders revolt is about
things that have happened in and to the
council since the last meeting and
probably the most obvious and public of
which has been the publication of the
business case for the merging of five
oops sorry now for East Kent District
Council's in late January whilst of the
council we have met since then it was
for the annual budget meeting which is
focused purely on the budget and medium
term financial strategy giving those
space to leaders report something which
some of you may have been grateful to
summarize planet alongside the district
councils of Canterbury Dover and shet
way are considering the business case
for a new single Council for East Kent
the largest of its kind in the country
what is proposed is a first in local
government the merger of four district
councils have not been attempted
anywhere else as far as we are aware it
is not anticipated to be a unitary
council as having discussed the options
it is clear that to achieve that will
require both governments and KCC
supports neither of which appears to be
readily available just now the
alternative is continuing as we are with
increasing budget pressures and deficits
to find in the years to 2025 and beyond
the estimates suggest that this council
would need to be finding an additional
15 million also in increased income ie
increasing fees charges and council tax
and or reduction in costs
essentially reductions in services to
residents this is a very real and
ongoing impact of the years of Tory
austerity interests you left that will
in neither of which appears to be
readily available just now sorry kishori
austerity reducing the money's coming to
council such as ours by some forty
percent the nature and structure of the
merger proposition is unusual a
fundamental reform of local government
which sharply reduces the numbers of
directors in that sense alone it is
something to be proud to be associated
with the published business case
explores economic potential a stronger
East Kent voice economies of scale and
resulting resilience potential for
greater investment in East Kent 6.8
million pounds of savings within two
years transitional costs recruits in a
year improved and consistent customer
experience and a transformation and
enhanced quality of service counselors
will be considering the local
implications before deciding on
Wednesday 22nd March whether to move to
public engagement and consultation I'm
sorry that should have been public
consultation engagement I think of the
previews yeah I'm going both endeavor in
July 2016 five councils in East Kent
decided the Commission this business
case for a new council to tested
financial and commercial case made sense
the business case structures to the
government treasury model clearly
identifies that the creation of a single
East End council is an ambitious but
logical next step for four councils the
projected savings required to meet
budget gaps on current projections to
2025 mean a required [ __ ] reduction
of some 60 million pounds between the
four of us by 2025 the best part of 42
million can be achieved through this
proposed merger alone these sense
districts already have a well
established track record of
collaboration and shared service and
they new single council
improve and streamline these services
given the significant recent changes in
the funding of local government we are
all clear things cannot continue as they
are the business case documents
background information council report
and a list of frequently asked questions
are available to view on the council
website and there is an ongoing program
of small group member briefings to
enable questions to the are answered and
consider length in private perhaps most
interestingly the results of all our
hard work to sort the finances council
over the last few years are here now
laid out for all to see the savings
dream up contributes are around
twenty-five percent of the total just
swelling should be between four councils
the indebtedness of the council appears
to be less than that of our colleagues
our council tax here should stand still
or slightly reduce not inexorably rise
that has been predicted and the results
of my own statements of business case
have supplied some of our colleague
councils their knee jerk reactions about
planet and its reputation challenged by
the figures we have all jointly
commissioned meanwhile here in phallus
out of the public eye at the council
budget meeting for the first time ever
the council budget was passed
unanimously supported by all parties
because the you keep run council had off
for transparency in briefings to all
councillors and listened and adopted
many of the comments made that was a
first in Sonic Council history and that
is just boring old stuff that doesn't
interest in these places they so this
spring is proving as busy as previously
anticipated the budget cycles running
very smoothly in spite of the very late
government changes assessment in
December 2016 some successful asset
disposals of a recent auction reserve
prices of around 180,000 became a
selling price of 540,000 which I trust
reassures to some extent councillor
Gregory regarding his recent fears for
the capital program I hope you can pass
it on to him council
the local plan consultation is in
progress and given how much
controversial commentary and
counterclaim i am now hearing i believe
there could just be some sort of
election due in may as well dreamland
would appear if you close to finally
having the necessary working capital it
needs available there's a building
change of youth public inquiry on the
near horizon and as you've already heard
in a question this evening yes another
promise about real detail concerning a
possible DCO application in the future
are truly peaceful few weeks too early
2017 just to keep us all on our toes and
when we have finished here this evening
we can all look forward to a couple of
by election results in the early hours
for the political anoraks of Ulster's i
commend this report to the council on
this very evening and look forward to
undoubtedly good natured and genteel
comment from other group leaders we
could just choose to leave the buffeting
to the incoming storm doors for a change
perhaps we shall see mr. chairman we
shall keep thank you very much i call
upon counselor paper to comment on i'll
ask questions in relation to these
report yeah Thank You chairman I now
know what it feels like to be pushed by
one's own Qatar's I spent hours shaping
insults the hurl accounts the world's
over the things that equal in this
report which you've now ruled out of
order so all that time has been wasted
but but I'll find a way to use them at
some later date I'm referring to the
report you actually gave i'm personally
pleased to hear about the merger that
we're looking towards at the moment i
know that there's lots of things that
have got to happen before a merger takes
place and the final shape of that
emerged authority may be very different
to the one that's being in visit right
now but i actually think that the days
of a single small district councillor
numbered the financial struggles will
deepen will eventually cause serious
operational difficulties the business
case for merger i think is strong and a
new larger council will improve the
strategic importance of East Kent
it's important that the existing
councils don't get bogged down worrying
about the detail of what not might be
lost or gained individually if the East
Kent councils don't sort something out
between them eventually someone probably
the government will do it for them this
is an opportunity to create something
new and exciting a unique situation
which could yield great benefits some
people are concerned that a larger
Authority nice had labor Authority there
which it probably won't be but nevermind
some people sorry about that I'll
withdraw that remark chairman Boudreau
some people are concerned that a larger
Authority makes decision-making more
remote for the residents but I believe
that an integral part of the merger
success will lie on devolution taken on
some responsibilities and powers from
County and perhaps more importantly
handing down some services to town and
parish councils some making more
decisions taken locally by local people
i think the merger potentially is a
great idea and we should bring it on i
have to comment on you taking credit for
the budget being unanimously passed
didn't have much to do with you counts
the world it was a tribute to your
finance team who were open and honest
and took note of helpful suggestions
made by opposition members allowance all
to take ownership for the budget I do
have to point out as well but I don't
have to point well now you you've
actually taken credit for you so but
never mind you did actually mention the
by-elections today I have to inform you
that when it's a violation you spell it
be why not be I I think a bi-election
might be something a little different
thank you katha well not even a quick
thank you really I notes what was said
and what we have been reduced to Thank
You chair I've got one of your comments
apparently since 1995 elected members
have had a budgetary briefing it's not
something that should be brought in and
also I understand that they went out to
consult with the public as well so it's
not something new I'm pleased that at
the first briefing that I went to where
we were concerned about the concept of
public engagement and I'm very pleased
to see that now has become consultation
engagement that I think the concept of
engagement is a bit vague consultation
people understand and the third point I
would like to make is that yes obviously
evolving powers and to local parish and
town councils has a lot of Merit so long
as they have adequate resources to carry
out what they are expected to do thank
you thank you Kosovo and for the Grove
to comment on or ask questions in
relation to the leadership or yes thank
you chairman yes it's I think the merger
is going to be a good thing for one and
all I don't think we can carry along the
paths that we have been but what I am
pleased to read in the report and also
see the actions in this chamber tonight
especially after the budget and medium
term financial strategy where everybody
voted for it is we seem to be getting
friendly with each other for a change
everything started work with each other
for a change the only thing I found
tonight a little bit disappointing was
the report was a bit like spy catcher
some of the points have been taken out
but never mind i'm quite happy with
what's going on thank you
after all and you find a worth
counteroffer 10 then the report from the
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
panel i call upon councillor david
saunders to present his report Thank You
chairman members since my last report on
the first of december 2016 seems an
awful long while ago now the overview
scrutiny panel is met on three occasions
and between them the working parties on
four occasions the report before you
this evening summarizes the scrutiny
content and recommendations where
appropriate of the Community Safety
Partnership I have to say I've been
working very diligently on very
important subjects and the corporate
performance review working party I would
confirm just a mention in case any
members haven't spotted it I would
confirm that the electoral registration
process review party has been replaced
within the work programme by the
dreamland working group who met on the
second of February's and agreed the
terms of reference and work program for
this subgroup and I'm looking for
forward to some interesting information
coming out of that subgroup that will
clarify the situation for all members
who have concerns another subject which
has been raised this evening on more
than one occasion but as you know I
always encourage members to attend the
overview and scrutiny meetings and in
this connection I would draw your
attention to agenda item 3 which is
headed the business case single East
Kent Council which is on the agenda
that's the overview and scrutiny agenda
for our next meeting on the second of
March so therefore any member wishing to
contribute further to this important
proposal and the council rule 20.1
I think the briefings that we've had
from the chief executive have been very
very helpful so far they may wish to
take the opportunity of attending the
meeting as I say which is on the second
of March and contributing chairman I
commend the report to the council thank
you thank you very much cancer Saunders
thank you thank you very much mr.
chairman and thank you counselor
Saunders for your report I would just
like to actually echo your words of
encouragement for members to attend
these meetings not just the overview and
scrutiny but also the other working
party groups which are open for all
members to attend and participate I do
try and attend although I'm not a member
of the corporate performance reviews
working party I'm sorry I'm struggling
with a long name at the most recent
leasing on the sixteenth of January the
Chairman councillor Campbell was asked
by financial officers whether they might
consider changing the name because it is
quite a mouthful and I think that
particular working party decided to keep
it as it is but I thought actually I
won't miss an opportunity to raise it
tonight it was very poorly attended
unfortunately by you kids at anything on
the sixteenth of January there were two
of your members absent with no
substitutes in fact the Chairman asked
me if I'd like to be a substitute for
one of the UK members and I thought well
that wouldn't really be appropriate so I
didn't but I I guess I definitely prefer
Minh in some ways but I think it is a
really important point so members of
this council should do their absolute
best to go to all the meetings for which
they have been asked to sit on the
committee and also attend the training
we had excellent training on effective
communication and questioning awkward
questions or something like that the
title on tuesday and i believe it was
quite poorly attended it's a shame
because they're put on for our benefit I
think we can all learn thinking thank
you very much
the gender item number 11 exceptional
hardship scheme i call upon council of
town in please Thank You chair when
council approved the 2017-18 council tax
support scheme on the first of December
2016 it's also agreed to receive a
report in respect of an exceptional
hardship scheme this latter scheme is
designed to provide a one-off financial
contribution to applicants that can
demonstrate exceptional hardship as a
result of changes to council tax support
the council has previously recognized
the inadequate central government
funding that has resulted in the need
for the review of council tax support by
tenet as well as other local authorities
members have approved a new scheme that
is jointly the most generous in Kent
overview and scrutiny panel considered
this exceptional hardship scheme on the
twenty-sixth of January and cabinet
approved this report on the thirty-first
of january i move that council approve
the recommendation Thank You cancer town
is there a second please second it's
check that's the koban thank you
thank you sure I would just ask counsel
to actually approve this I think it's
absolutely vital that there is a backup
scheme for those is book could be put
into financial hardship thank you thank
you cancel game console Campbell oh yes
thank you okay I just like to take
counsel of town and broke this through
to the Oviatt scrutiny panel and took on
board some of the suggestions positive
suggestions that were amazing including
a new scheme the only disappointing
feature is that we've had to take on on
trust the actual application form which
is not quite ready yet so we'll look at
that when it comes available but I do as
the counselor just said see all members
to urge them to a key support this
scheme thank you thank you very much do
you members agree thank you very much
agenda item number 12 then the council
tax statutory resolution would members
please refer once more to the
supplementary agenda number one I will
advise in accordance with council
procedural 17.6 I will call for a
recorded vote on the motion or any
amendments and substantive motions I
call upon councillor town names please
Thank You chef this report sets out the
calculation of panax council tax and
proposes the increase to be effective
for 2017 18 it includes reference to the
preceptors listed in paragraph one point
three point eight whose precepts TDC
collect along with its own counsel text
council approved a 2017 18 budget on the
9th of februari which assumed an
increase of 4.4 pounds 95 for AB and E
property this represents an increase of
two-point-three percent I would also
like to draw members attention to the
relatively low increase in planets
council tax injuries as shown in
paragraph 2 3 it is below the overall
increase or three point eight three
percent and only Kent Fire and Rescue
has a smaller increase
TDC this report and its recommendation
follow a structure has laid down in law
and it represents a statutory resolution
I move the recommendations thank you is
there a second to please second
Thank You chairman councillor Ashby casa
Bainbridge cancer bayford class-a
braidwood counselor Buckley Gaza
Campbell causa Glenn Coleman Cook has a
Keith Coleman cook that's a collar
Catholic constant owned causa crow Brown
has a Curran Casa della Casa Dexter casa
Dixon that's 10 sorry cuz edgewood's
cancer ella de casa Jeremy fairbrass
castle in fairbrass casa falken cancer
Fenner casa game does the grove casa
hatin casa Hillman castle house casa Jay
Jones cancer Johnston cancer Larkins
castlemartin cancer matter face
councillor Parsons casa linda Piper the
castle stuart Piper agree Casa Linda
pots that's the ROI pots cancer res
ecchi casa david saunders chasm a
Saunders cancer savage cancer shankh
casa hasta las purchasing counselor
Taylor castle Taylor Smith casa
Tomlinson casa townend casa wells thank
you
thank you very much Thank You members
that represents another unanimous
agreement in the council thank you for
that agenda item number 13 the calendar
of council meetings I move that the
council approves the Canada meetings for
2017-18 and 2018-19 as set out in annex
one to the report with the vice-chairman
three second seconded to members agree
thank you gender item number 14 a report
on the urgent individual cabinet member
decision the purpose of this item is
only to inform council that this
individual cabinet member decision was
exempt from calling in accordance with
the overview and scrutiny procedure
rules would members please note the
report thank you that concludes the
business for the meeting of this council